did friends and family try to intervene
at all especially near the end
I don't think so why not to be honest
when I got there
the day the incident happened there was
no friends over there
I was really surprised it was just me
and Melanie and Melanie families you
know a few people but people I used to
see him every day in his house on his
face time nobody was there
that's why it's kind of concerning me
what happened
what was going on the day before like we
need to find out I mean not me but the
police will find out but there is
something that just
what do you think happened I personally
think he was on medication and he fall
asleep in a bathtub and that's what
happened that's what I personally think
but we don't know until we find out the
real you know and you said you saw
aerosol cans in the bathroom correct so
there could have been that going on also
yes
when was the last time you spoke to
Aaron well we've been messaging on
Instagram and text message like days
before but the last time he facetimed me
from Santa Monica his he was at the
dentist office so he said come down here
I'm doing a root canal
and it's it's very painful I want you to
hold my hand
I said I can't do it and I had some
plans you know to go to work I said I'll
come see you tomorrow
and and I couldn't go see him because I
think he was traveling after that he's
doing some kind of touring small
concerts and different states there had
been concern where fans had been
reaching out saying hey stop him from
doing these drugs and stop him from
doing the huffing had you seen that yes
of course and did you ask him about that
yes we had a conversation together and
he said what do you want me to do
I said can we please check you into
rehab you do have the Assurance Melanie
told me we can get you to the rehab and
he said is that what you want me to do I
said well I want you to do it for you
than for me because I don't want to see
you like this
because okay I'll do it just give me a
week and I'll do it give me two weeks
and I'll do it and it never happened why
don't you think you want to go to rehab
because I think the mental illness he
has and the addiction he had I think was
controlling his life but Aaron also was
a very lonely person in his mind you
know he had friends he had family but I
think he's a type of a guy he wants to
be surrounded with
family
blood related family he loved his son
you know he loved kids and in a point he
says can you be the Godfather of my son
I said of course I will be The Godfather
but I think he was
giving too much
but he was very lonely in his own mind
he wanted to be hugged he wanted to be
loved but one person can't give all that
you know I think he we needed more
people there but
people not they're they were not there
I think they give up on him do you think
his family gave up on him I think they
give up on him and with all the respect
to his family and I saw the video
yesterday
his brother Nick was crying of course
it's emotional his blood his brother
of course he's hurting a lot but
I don't think he should have ever give
up on Aaron
knowing his brother has a mental illness
and I don't think anyone ever should
give up on someone who has mental
illness
because this would happen to people
you know they don't think the way we
think
they're different they're not different
but their mind is different so we need
to love and support and never give up on
that end of the day
was this his way of ending it all do you
think or do you think it was just a
tragic accident I think it's a tragic
accident because we love life he had so
many plans even though he had mental
issues or addiction but he loved life I
don't think and I don't want to believe
he end up his life I think it was a
tragic accident is he finally at peace
now and if you could say one last thing
to him what would you say I just want to
tell him I love you
and I will always be
by his son's side I will always do my
best for him to give him the most
beautiful childhood
and I was always support and love and
care his son and his family
and I think he will be very happy to
knowing that I'm going to be
his son big brother or hopefully I can
be the Godfather so I can you know
be more deep in and help me make sure
he's good
that I will do all my best
to support his son I think that's the
only thing he left in this world
it was his beautiful son
and I will do everything for him in this
world to make him happy
in heaven
[Music]